Зарплати топ-чиновників в Україні зросли
у три з половиною-п’ять разів,
а з першого січня у два з половиною рази
буде збільшена
і зарплата народним депутатам і перевищуватиме 100 тисяч гривень,
стверджує колишній віцепрем’єр і міністр соцполітики Павло Розенко.
Це одразу спричинило багато спекуляцій на тему зарплат можновладців.
У парламенті ці дані називають фейком
і заперечують значне збільшення зарплат нардепів.
За словами голови Верховної Ради Дмитра Разумкова,
буде лише індексація зарплат народних обранців приблизно на 3 тисячі гривень,
пов’язана зі збільшенням прожиткового мінімуму,
і про суми понад 100 тисяч гривень не йдеться.
Якщо зазирнути у декларації топ-чиновників, приміром
першого заступника міністра культури,
молоді та спорту Анатолія Максимчука,
то помітні суттєві зміни в доходах.
Так 16 грудня була задекларована зарплата
у розмірі 157 тисяч гривень,
потім 27 грудня - ще одна сума
у розмірі 248 тисяч гривень.
Загалом 405 тисяч гривень.
Частина цієї суми - ще виплати за листопад
і різноманітні надбавки та премії,
а не "гола" зарплата за грудень.
Але факт той, що дохід чиновника у грудні
у 40 разів перевищив рівень
середньої зарплати в Україні.
При цьому шеф Максимчука, міністр культури, молоді та спорту
Володимир Бородянський стверджує,
що його перший заступник
отримав за весь час роботи у міністерстві
з жовтня по грудень
лише 326 тисяч гривень.
Суми не співпадають, і різниця величезна.
Бородянський пояснює такі зарплати у своєму відомстві
необхідністю запрошувати найкращих фахівців, і щоб чиновницький дохід
відповідав ринковим умовам та міг конкурувати
з комерційними структурами.
Мустафі Найєму, який нині працює заступником гендиректора "Укроборонпрому",
також у грудні нарахували майже пів мільйона гривень.
Найєм пояснює: або досвідчені злодії з маленькими зарплатами і великими відкатами,
або менеджери з білою і відкрито
задекларованою зарплатою.
Прем’єр Олексій Гончарук також запевняє,
що з високими прозорими зарплатами вже не буде тіньових схем і корупції у владі.
Він закликає не спекулювати цифрами,
бо у деяких випадках міністри у грудні отримали із затримкою
виплати за попередні місяці.
Багато років в Україні чиновники офіційно отримували по кілька тисяч гривень,
а за тіньовими схемами крали десятки
і сотні мільйонів доларів
або отримували зарплати у конвертах, підкреслив Гончарук.
Справді, щоб побороти корупцію серед держслужбовців,
аби ті не спокушалися на "додатковий підробіток",
лобіюючи інтереси тих чи інших олігархічних
чи фінансово-промислових груп,
у чиновників мають бути адекватні зарплати.
Це потрібно також, щоб залучати на державну службу професіоналів.
Але що таке "адекватні зарплати",
у всіх своє бачення.
У багатьох європейських країнах різниця між зарплатою
топ-чиновників і пересічних громадянин - у 4-5 разів.
Приміром, у Німеччині зарплата міністрів становить
приблизно 15 тисяч євро на місяць до сплати податків.
Це вп’ятеро більше, ніж середня місячна зарплатня у ФРН.
В Україні ж зарплати членів уряду перевищують середню зарплатню  по країні в 4 рази.
Зарплата українських міністрів за друге півріччя 2019 року
без надбавок у середньому становила
40 тисяч гривень.
А середня зарплатня українця - близько 11 тисяч гривень.
Втім, в Україні склалася багаторічна практика
нарахування до зарплати різноманітних надбавок, премій та бонусів.
Таке є і в європейських державах, але в українських держустановах цим дуже спекулюють.
Особливо наприкінці року, коли бюджетні гроші,
які залишилися у міністерстві,
намагаються будь-що витратити, щоб наступного року не урізали бюджет.
Тоді й починається виписування величезних премій,
іноді розміром у 2-3 зарплати.
Так було і за попередньої влади, і за нинішньої.
При цьому баланс між зарплатами топ-чиновників
та іншими бюджетниками не дотримано -
різниця може бути у 20-30 разів і більше.
Такі дії розколюють суспільство і можуть призвести до соціальних протистоянь,
застерігають експерти і додають:
варто переглянути процедуру нарахування зарплат і премій.
Або піти ще радикальнішим шляхом:
приміром, щоб підвищення стосувалося вже наступних посадовців,
а не робилося самим собі.